I told you last week that the nickname Moscow
Mitch is really sticking to Republican Senate
majority leader Mitch McConnell and he absolutely
hates it.
He's been dubbed Moscow Mitch because he consistently
stands in the way of every single proposal
to try to stop future foreign election interference
including and primarily from Russia.
People have been showing up at his public
events and just chanting Moscow Mitch Louder
than his microphone will go.
It's great.
And this has now been more and more mainstream
speaker of the house.
Nancy Pelosi has now referred to Mitch McConnell
as Moscow.
Mitch, this was during an appearance in, uh,
Springfield, Illinois a day or two ago.
Take a look at this.
So we've sent our legislation to the Senate,
the central legislation to the Senate.
Mosgiel Mitch says that he is the grim reaper.
Imagine describing yourself as the grim reaper
that he's going to bury all this legislation.
Well, we have news for him,
so don't be confused.
I'm not telling you this to praise Nancy Pelosi
as anything other than a democrat.
But this is notable because this is a story
that's building with more and more people
being aware of it.
More and more disturbing revelations about
Mitch McConnell's foreign relationships.
The Washington Post has reported about Mitch
McConnell's, Russia ties, even Republicans
are increasingly calling Mitch McConnell's
efforts to block these bills, to stop election
interference, anti-American.
And of course the republican concern trolls
are now out in full force.
How lacking in decorum and politeness.
Nancy Pelosi, oh my calling a fellow congressional
leader.
She's speaker of the house.
He's uh, a majority leader in the Senate using
nicknames.
How terrible.
Wait a second.
Donald Trump's entire presidential campaign
and administration is based on nicknames.
That doesn't matter.
They don't care about that.
It's different when Trump does it or something.
They just love to pick up any old narrative
that's convenient.
At the time, Nancy Pelosi uses a nickname.
Oh, she's bad.
Mass shooting video games cause violence.
Moscow Mitch nicknames are Bad Cajun Kids.
Obama did it back a few years ago.
Uh, she stooping so low and disgracing the
office of the speaker.
Wait a second.
Trump has disgraced the office of the presidency
100 times over.
Nancy Pelosi saying, Moscow, Mitch is not
the problem here and I actually, I know some
people in my audience might not like this.
I commend Nancy Pelosi in one particular sense.
Branding and messaging and politics are super
important.
They are effective ways to actually win crooked
Hillary Lion, ted, sleepy, Joe Biden.
These things actually work.
It wouldn't hurt Democrats to understand that
this is the reality and to try to use it to
our advantage.
I'm, I'm not saying we use violence.
I'm not saying we don't have to be right on
policy.
We do still have to be right on policy.
We've got to have the right ideas.
We still have to run good campaigns.
We completely fail at the local level in many
ways over the last 20 years, as I've talked
about as the left has done, but it would be
okay for Democrats to use some of these more
innocuous but effective strategies against
Republicans, uh, give them their a taste of
their own medicine.
I've interviewed George Lakoff who talks so
much about framing and branding and he has
explained the left is at a structural disadvantage.
The Wright has branded many of their ideas
so simply that the left can't counter them
as simply.
I've given this example, there was a position
on the right, abortion is murder, therefore
it should be illegal.
The left doesn't take the opposite position,
which is abortion is lovely and you should
be able to kill anyone you want, even up until
they're 12 years old or whatever.
Some cartoonish opposition would be, which
really exposes how extreme the right wing
position is on abortion.
The left says, okay, it'd be better to avoid
the need for abortions and we know how to
do that, which is a free access to contraceptives
combined with comprehensive same sex sex education,
not same sex education, sex education.
We know that that reduces the need for abortions,
but even when they are necessary, it's important
that they be safe and accessible and affordable
because we know that one of the worst things
that can happen is women choosing to get so-called
back alley abortions.
We've already sort of lost the thread because
the right has abortion is murder and it should
be illegal.
So we could really benefit from just understanding
branding.
And I know I'm sort of off the rails from
Nancy Pelosi calling Mitch McConnell, Moscow
Mitch, but I am not going to fault Nancy Pelosi
for if it's what she's doing, understanding
the effect of branding and nicknames.
And this isn't really stooping below where
we're comfortable stooping.
I don't want to do a lot of this stuff that
the right does.
Uh, but just understanding branding and framing
I think is something that I've been desperately
begging the left to understand.
Maybe Moscow.
Mitch is a small part of that.
We've got a great show for you today.
We will then have a bonus show for our members
after the show next week.
The show will be sort of on vacation.
We won't be here, but we're not going dark
and we're not having guest hosts.
We're actually going to a debut five deep
dive episodes full show deep dives that we've
been working on for a couple of months.
Uh, they will be on a variety of different
topics and that is the plan for next week.
So we will be on summer vacation, but there
will be new stuff a lot of which I think you
will like.
But before any of that,
we've still got a great program for you.
The David Pakman
show